pc légumes teaser de la 2e la dernière
de fo doit sortir aujourd'hui d'échelle
citroën au portugal presque 4 millions
de voitures produites depuis 1949
nostalgie nostalgie la saga d'une
voiture pas comme les autres alain
chabod présenté pour la première fois au
public lors du salon de l'auto de 1948
en présence du président vincent auriol
lui-même l'a2 frau avait en fait germé
dès 1935 dans le cerveau des ingénieurs
de chez citroën
c'était l'époque du front populaire et
il fallait inventer une voiture
accessible au plus grand nombre
le cahier des charges précise et
d'ailleurs que l'engin devait pouvoir
transporter deux personnes et 50 kg de
pommes de terre à 60 kilomètres/heure en
ne consommant que 3 litres aux 100 s'il
vous plaît depuis le concept de la deux
chats bien évolué passant du fameux
prototype à un seul phare à l'élégante
charleston que tout le monde connaît
malgré le succès qui fit sa renommée
s'il a des pattes méthode plus fabriqué
en france depuis 1988
seul lusine de mangue aldo portugal
continuant à en assurer la production
les deux ultimes modèles qui sortiront
des chaînes aujourd'hui sont destinés au
futur musée citroën
la deux chevaux n'a pas pour autant
terminé sa brillante carrière assez
amoureux sont encore légion et aux
tarifs collectionneurs le cours de la 2
2 risque plutôt de s'envoler